[Music]
this is a bad thing that happened
a pregnant woman was killed at a factory
during a job interview what
yeah oh damn so they're giving uh
they're giving this woman a tour of this
factory in belarus she wants to work at
and then they're walking her through the
factory her hair is really long
oh my god you know where it's going
right no way yeah oh i hate this stuff i
hate the hair stuff her uh hair gets
caught in this machine
and it just it yeah rips her scalp off
aren't they supposed to be wearing hair
nets that's the whole issue right there
it's like you're supposed to kind of
test our hats
or have emergency scissors so if it
pulls on you could just go like once you
see scissors they don't have osha there
the crazy thing is that it
i guess when it when it took her hair in
it wrapped around her neck and it was
strangling oh my god so she got scalped
and choked well the fact that she got
scared actually saved her a little bit i
mean she died from her injuries like
days later oh she died from right now
what about the dude giving the tour he
was a [ __ ] cpr certified or some [ __ ]
he would i guess not they didn't do
there's no reporter i don't know if cpr
is going to help it dude i think if they
did cpr there's a scalp woman it would
probably help her a lot yeah they have
other skills sometimes
maneuver oh yeah i thought it was like a
willy wonka situation where like they
they were touring the place and they're
like i told you not to do that
and then she wanted to eat the bubble
gum she turned into a blueberry and then
she floated yeah that's what i thought
how it works in belarus but i know out
here when that [ __ ] happens it's like
it's the fault no matter what like if
hair gets caught in any kind of
mechanism it's the fault of the place
because it happened at the uh cause they
let you in that way because there's a
protocol like that happened at the uh
the go-kart place when um that girl was
in a go-kart her hair wasn't tied back
and she didn't have a helmet so then it
got caught in the rotator i don't know
if they follow protocol in belarus if
you if you've seen belarus yeah
they don't um it's um
so one of these youtubers that i like
watching he's kind of like um
[ __ ] i forgot his name his channel but
he goes to former soviet union countries
so he travels to all these like um
industrial like countries yeah like
these up and coming countries that are
like you just like whoa you went there
and then he just travels and it's like a
travel vlogger but he's going to like
crazy ass places and belarus is one of
them and it's pretty but then you can
really see the the former communism in
there if you know what i mean you know
it's like if north korea just came to
like live and then you went to visit
there like things aren't updated
right a lot of alcoholism a lot of
sadness you know even the rules are
crazy so like in powerlifting um you
know they they'll they have their own
olympics and they'll like switch every
single
year to a different country to compete
and that's like their olympics uh one
year when it was in
minx
belarus a lot of the top champions
actually um didn't go
that's how crazy it was like to instead
of it's worth not going because of it's
possible you might get detained or
you're not gonna
like you might get robbed or a flight
back or whatever where's belarus dude
in europe yeah a lot of people would be
like nah i'm good and they didn't but
it's a former it's a former eastern bloc
like it's former soviet union that's how
crazy it was so they just opened up like
in the 80s or something
or maybe a little bit belarus is one of
the countries that
russia could technically invade through
right
all right thinking that's a different
place poland that's just europe i don't
know you could go through europe it's
not andre arlovski's from that's so
that's all the things
dang the the kicker is adding that this
woman was pregnant dude that just makes
all the more i know so sad man so what
kind of injuries did she
she got strangled that's how yeah so she
was what happened it's like a i'll show
you a picture of the machine
oh yeah and this is her she's beautiful
too look at that
and then uh louise is sad when they're
they're hot and i hate that that's sad
but like she looks like a model yeah she
looks like a model she's gonna i thought
everyone in belarus looked like a model
is that is that the machine this is the
machine yeah so it has this like
spinning thing down there and i'm
guessing
how come she was so close to the machine
that scares the [ __ ] out of me models
akka
dude have you seen eastern europe you
see like the hottest models working like
at a [ __ ]
like
duck stand or something yeah so she's a
21 year old mom to be and she wants to
work in a factory like this because
there ain't no [ __ ] jobs and [ __ ] i'm
telling you dude yeah why should i find
though that's like that that's that's
that's normal i mean i mean attracting
one
if she was here like then people would
like worship her and be like no you're
not working old factory yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's not ken doesn't become the
only ass dudes and wives did you just
have a factory do you guys have a
factory for your noodles no they closed
down
no just kidding these are killing the
dog
gingerbread news.com shameless plug and
have you toured the factory no it's in
uh overseas
were you saying your mom out of what my
mom had a funny injury when i was four
funny injuries man yeah she was trying
to like make speaking of funny injuries
huh
this reminded me no she's really funny
about moms you know mom's getting hurt
and stuff
and then my mom she was trying to make
pork chops and then uh
i think she messed up where like the
pork chops were still wet or whatever
she was frying them so she threw it on
the pan and then the hot oil came up and
splattered her on the face
and that's when she became vegetarian
and then she came crying to me for help
but i got scared and so i was like three
or four or something and why the [ __ ]
did she go to a four-year-old friend i
was the only one at home i was like oh
monster and then i ran away what would
you have done oh
i don't know cpr or something i don't
like that you're gonna put [ __ ]
band-aids on it's always cpr he's like
cpr i guess throw [ __ ] baby lotion on
her face i don't know dude that's awful
he's like that person is about to burn
to death and breath like give him cpr
right now or aloe vera
i remember i remember uh waking up
hearing my dumb ass grandma fall from
the kitchen because she yeah dude
because
dude man she was too adventure for her
[ __ ] size like she she couldn't reach
the dish at the top so she climbed up on
the counter
[ __ ] slipped and fell i heard crash
and she
and then it was like just me and her at
home or something my parents were there
that day i got up and i went went up to
her and she's on the floor she's like ow
ow like i'm like oh no i'm like
that's why you're not supposed to go up
on the counter grandma that's what
happens you start to get hurt and that's
bad and i was just scolding her the
whole time her and then bart would give
her cpr i would scold her and bart would
come in and cpr my grandma
that's the compressions right there i
scolded the [ __ ] out of her she learned
her lesson this isn't my story but this
is a really good story that my buddy did
shout out to my boy heinrich he uh
heinrich so this dude when he was a kid
he liked to play pranks on his
grandmother all the time so he had a
wolf mask that he had and it looked
really scary really real he put a
volleyball
all the way inside of it so the eyes
looked white oh [ __ ] and then he put it
and she i guess his grandmother was like
really superstitious about like you know
demons yeah demons and all that [ __ ]
right
so
he
put the mask over a pillow in the bed
and then you could see the head [ __ ]
in the bed just like this right
he turns off the light and he's like
grandma grandma and she runs all the way
up the stairs and they're hiding in
another room oh my god and all she hears
like all day here is like a scream
and then like
and
oh my god and they were like oh my god
but she was luckily okay but like when
he told that story i was like dude
you're a piece of [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
up prank that you do to your grandma she
didn't get she was okay thankfully did
you tell us a prank bro yeah they did
and then she was like oh dude's sick
sick
she's like a stretcher she's like oh you
guys
you got me bro she looks at the camera
subscribe like yo you have to go to the
hospital already i think she was fine
but she was like really shook enough my
grandpa did some [ __ ] like that to me
where i was like going up and down the
sidewalk full sprint on a bike
like
this
and then we had like these tall bushes
that separated the house
yeah my uh my grandpa was hiding behind
the bush and as i was coming out he just
jumps out ah
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me so i
turned off to the side and i flew over
the handlebars i landed my face on the
concrete and i lost like two of my teeth
oh my god i think he felt pretty bad did
he tell you it was a prank
you have no teeth and you're like you're
like oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] got me bro give your cpr
like subscribe yeah yeah yeah follow for
more pranks hit that notification bell
how many times have you lost teeth like
that in your life or just once i think
oh that was the only time yeah how did
what happens when you lose teeth as a
kid what do they do you just nothing you
just leave it you have no teeth you just
have no teeth until that part of it
grows until the big daddy teeth come out
yeah big daddy teeth yeah
is that what we call it i was curious
what happened because i never lost a
tooth as a kid that way oh but did you
did you have [ __ ] up teeth after that
like did you have to get braces i had
braids i think i was gonna get a
bracelet
your destiny is there some [ __ ] up
weird statistic about like death by hair
accidents on google or something you
want to cut your hair now yeah a little
bit yeah by hair i think it's time
statistics
we should make it more specific like
death by hair for fine babes fine babes
yeah i think we're safe then
having yeah hair related hair related
injuries should be interesting related
hot babe injuries yeah like remember
that one chick who was doing the [ __ ]
uh corn thing oh my god
oh and her haircut put the corn on a
[ __ ] like a drill a power drill and
eat it trying to do the thing and then
her hair got cut and literally just
ripped off like a whole oh my god you
see that [ __ ] she was so was she fine
though yeah how many hot people died a
day can you look up that
how many hot people died there's a whole
website dedicated to that unnecessary
hot babe deaths that could have been
saved by jk we could have saved those
girls gotta save them dude
we shouldn't have shot at the trump
tower shot at belarus
is that the next trip
i'll open up a factory so models can
work it says here uh
approximately 700 people die on average
every year in the us due to extreme
hotness [ __ ]
no he's right so they're radiating so
much hotness after they [ __ ] die
jesus christ their body can't sustain it
from from heat exhaustion huh that's
[ __ ] up it's from extreme huge but i
just assume that's where is it mostly
extremely ugly
[Laughter]
when do you have to register is where
your looks lie in the spectrum of uh do
you think a chick so ugly the bar walks
up and tries to give her cpr
[Laughter]
oh we didn't know how to give her cpr on
the shoulder
they got shot bro you know what there's
no uh stats on the i couldn't find
anything in the hair thing but i do know
that there's 231 go-kart related debts
what the [ __ ]
yeah you can die at go-karting don't
know during the in in a in a 10-year
span
you're talking about like k-1 formula
racing type stuff where you're like
they're pretty fast yeah those are
pretty crazy i'm sure a percentage of
those are from hair getting caught in
the [ __ ] thing behind you and a
percentage there's probably a hot
[ __ ]
crazy
you know back at a speed zone you know
off to 60 like back in the day we used
to go there and they didn't give you
nothing for her there are tons of girls
along here what they don't they give you
the whole [ __ ] mesh sock thing that
they put and then the helmet they do
that now yeah i think they give them the
hotties but not nonnies
because when they're too hot they're
like just let your hair flow out
can you just imagine them doing as you
walk in hotty or naughty actually
here oh that's a naughty we got a
naughty over here
we got a real ugly like you're on this
side you're on no no you're on this side
i'm a hottie no no you trust me or not
[Laughter]
get all the guys from pizza to come look
at this chick
[Music]
you